Welcome to the tdkr seminar everyone. Before we
introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some
rules as usual. First of all, please mute yourself
during the talk. If you have immediate questions,
you're welcome to unmute and ask, or otherwise,
please use the chat room to pose your questions,
so that we can address them in the
q&a session at the end. So again,
today's seminar is open to external audience, so
no classified discussion is allowed. Finally, the
talk will be recorded and uploaded to our YouTube
channel. Now, let me introduce our speaker. It is
an honor to your host, Christopher Cass, who is
the vice president of modeling and simulation at
Giulia hub, the Director of Scientific Research at
piomas Ai, co PI of the Giulia hub at MIT, and the
lead developer of the site ml open source software
organization, or his work in mechanistic machine
learning. His work is credit for the 15,000 times
made up of NASA Launch Services simulations and
recent state demonstrate a 60 times to 570 times
acceleration of a model more than occur tools in
HVAC simulation, and increase the US Air Force
artificial intelligence accelerator scientific
excellence award. He is the lead developer of the
Pumas project, and has received a top presentation
award at every aclp in the last three years, for
improving methods for uncertainty quantification,
automated GPU acceleration of mixed nonlinear
mixed effects, modeling and machine learning
assist on construction of the NLM the
models with all these achievements,
Chris received the emerging scientist award from
iSap. Today, he will talk about generalizing
scientific machine learning and differentiable
simulation beyond continuous models. Please enjoy
the wonderful talk. Now without further
ado, let me head over to Christopher.
Yeah, thank you. I mean, I'll jump right into
this. Thank you for the nice introduction. So what
I want to talk about today is scientific machine
learning. Right. And what scientific machine
learning is, is, you know, I think that this this
seminar, everyone's kind of familiar with it. But
the core idea behind scientific machine learning
is that, you know, you have this information in
your scientific models that you don't necessarily
have in your data. So for example, you know,
with general relativity, there is no data set
that, you know, kind of in Capture captures,
you know, what general relativity is right. You
know, there is no 3 billion line website that,
you know, like what Google has for generativity,
there are 1000s of experiments that have shown us
that it's true, there isn't that data set, right?
So if we want to build these AI systems that are,
you know, correct and predictive, what we want to
do is, we want to be able to use that knowledge
as though we had data without having to require
that we just go out there and gather that data,
right. So how do we do that? How do we build
a machine learning kind of system that is
incorporating all of the knowledge that we know,
and using that as a starting point, and then using
our data to then go beyond the pieces that we
know, this is what we're doing with scientific
machine learning. And the core point of what I
want to hit here on here is that differentiable
simulation is a very, very specific way of doing
scientific machine learning. And I want to talk
about how differential simulation is hard. But
it's worth developing more time in right. So, you
know, I want to really develop what differentiable
simulation is, why it's important, why it's a hard
way of doing scientific machine learning, but why
it has a lot of payoff. And so first of all, what
is our approach the science of machine learning,
a lot of what we'll be talking about today will be
in this this realm of these universal approximator
differential equations, also kind of short handed
to universal differential equations. The core idea
behind them is it's a very general object where
you say, I have differential equations, which
are defined in part by Universal approximator.
So what's a universal approximator? A universal
approximator is any kind of object that is a
representative of space of functions from Rn to
Rm. So a neural network is your classic example,
where you there is the universal approximator
theorem, which says that for sufficiently large
neural network, so sufficiently large in terms
of the size of the hidden layers or the number
of hidden layers, then with a sufficiently large
neural network, you can approximate any possible
function, if you can find weights of the neural
network such that its inputs go out to the output
such that over the whole, you know, over a whole
domain omega f of x, f of x is the neural network
of x is approximately f of x for all you know, X
in there with within some epsilon right? There's
So there's a way to be able to formalize this
this property that, you know, a sufficiently large
neural network can approximate any any possible
function that's sufficiently large. The reason why
neural networks are used for a lot of these cases
is because they overcome curse of dimensionality.
So for sufficiently large dimensions, they might
be a nice object to do this, but it's not the only
object that we use here. There's also you can
also make use of Polynomial Chaos expansions,
you can make use of lasagna expansions you can
use for a series, all of these things are function
approximator. Now a lot of them are designed in
1d. And so the, if you use a use a tensor product
approach to build up these function, approximator
is like a Fourier series into higher dimensions,
you have exponential growth in the number of
terms. This is the curse of dimensionality. And
so in some cases, we use some things that overcome
personal dimensionality. Other cases you don't.
But the core idea here is that you have function
approximator, so you have things that can stand in
for functions that you don't know. And what you do
is you build models that that make use of all this
information, you know, so here, for example, is a
version of lustful terror. So we have a version of
lock Voltaire, where we say, you know, X is the
number of bunnies, and if I leave bunnies alone,
I get exponentially more bunnies. And if I leave
wolves alone, I get exponentially well less wolves
over time. And I there's something more to this
model that I don't know, there is something,
there's something extra and, and whatever this
extra thing is, it's it's a it's who knows,
it's something that happens when we put
rabbits and wolves together. But you know,
they never teach you that in elementary school
for some reason. So what happens when we put
rabbits and wolves together, that's what this
model is saying. And so what we then do is we,
we, we train this, this model, we write, we train
this neural network, this function approximator,
to capture the thing that we did not know how
to model, right. And so that's, that's step one,
right? So and once you do that, you didn't have
a computational representation of the thing that
you did not know how to model, right. So, you
know, you don't necessarily know what it is,
but you have a object, a computational object
that is able to do input output relationships,
such that the thing that you did not know how
to model is correctly chosen to now match the
data. So it's, it's once it's trained, it
becomes a function of the product becomes
an approximation to the function that you did not
otherwise know how to write down, right? And now,
what can you do with that? Well, you can do all
sorts of analysis, right, you can say, you know,
understand the sensitivities of the piece
of the model that you that you did not know,
you can bind this to Cobian, you can, you can
do all these things that you would want to do
with a model just on the thing that you previously
did not know how to model. And one of the things
that we then commonly do is we perform a symbolic
regression, right? We, we say, well, you know, now
that we've learned in such a way that we've made
use of all of our prior information, let's now try
to understand that that model element in terms of
some more primitive pieces, some pieces that are
representative of mechanistic portions, which if
we were to write a model ourselves, we would use
these these, these pieces, right. And so you can
then do this kind of symbolic regression process,
and have it spit out equations which are more more
readable, and they actually tend to improve the
generalizability of the approach as well. So it
to really kind of understand this entire approach,
I want to kind of walk through this step by step.
So here, we start with just standard machine
learning. Right? So the standard machine learning
approach here that we're just gonna do is neural
ote, right? Just pure machine learning, u prime
equals a neural network, right? So we're saying,
learn any possible function such that I've
represented this time series, I go from zero
to 21 days worth of data, right? So I just learned
from zero to 21 day, just that many data points,
I fit the model and extrapolate forward, then this
is the first data from the first 21 days in the
Wuhan region of China from the COVID 19. outbreak.
And now you look at this and you go well,
the lines for the estimated from the from the
model are completely not fitting the data at all
after the training regime. Right. And that you are
right, this is what happens with machine learning,
right machine learning does not necessarily act
extrapolate well to outside of its dataset. So so
what I'm what I'm saying here is that, you know,
we have a lot of prior information, though, like
I told you that this is an epidemic model. And so
when you look at this, you go, Well, of course,
that's the start of an exponential growth, right.
But the machine learning model does not know that
information, right? We just told the machine
learning model, hey, here's here's a bit of data
from the start of a pandemic. Go for it, right.
It doesn't even know what a pandemic is. It's just
it's fitting the data and it's just extrapolating
forward. So what happens if we tell it a little
bit about what happened? endemic is. So here now
we have this form of a universal od E. So yeah,
so this is a version of a one of these epidemic
models, where we now have a susceptible
individuals, that's s, we have the susceptible
individuals become exposed, the exposed
individuals become infected over time, they either
recover or they die, right. So this is the SEIR D
model. Now, one of the interesting things that
happens when we go to this kind of mechanistic
model form is that we now can use heterogeneous
data and prior information inside of this process,
right? So for example, we can know a lot of the
details about some of the the ratios between some
of the reaction rates in this model, because they
can be directly estimated from what percentage of
people are, what percentage of people die versus
recover, right. So we don't need to actually use
our time series to get a lot of these values, we
can use prior information to be able to say, well,
the percentage of folks who die from this disease
is, you know, mu, and you know, it's so you can
start to write down these values directly from
other sources of information, right. So now we're
bringing in other information in a scientific way
where you were using all the knowledge that we
have. But the piece that I want to highlight here
is that when we talking about something like you
know, COVID-19 exposure, that was very dependent
on the region of the world that you were in,
right, so for example, you know, if you're in
China versus if you're in Sweden, versus if you're
in Italy, versus we own which state of the United
States you're in, there are completely different
exposure patterns to, to the virus. And so writing
down a simple equation for what how exposure to
COVID-19 occurred, is not necessarily easy to do.
But what we can do is we can say, well, we know a
lot about this model. But the piece that we don't
know how to model is the exposure term. So let's
just make that one exposure term be our neural
network, you know, the the function that we did
not know how to model, let's put a neural network
right there. And now we have all the info from all
the prior information we have, we have a machine
learning model, extending it, and then from that,
we're able to then see that for just zero to
21 days worth of data, we extrapolate forward,
and we can extrapolate much better, right, we're
able to get about 20 days of extrapolation, right.
And so the key key here is that we're using a lot
of other prior information, you know, it's like,
we're not gaining something for free, we are
putting more into the system and getting more
out of it. But there's other more concrete ways to
also be able to understand this. So if our if our
neural network is always outputting, a positive
value, so we just, you know, make the last layer
be a square, or a square function or an absolute
value, then what we know is just looking at the
equations is that s prime is always negative. And
so just from this information, we can actually
infer a lot of things. So what we have is a model
that starts with an exponential growth phase,
and then E will go up, and then I'll have a peak
and go down. So we'll have a single peak. And so
you can think about this as now, you know, the
world of machine learning was about function.
approximator is right, that's where I started.
But by design, what I've done now, as I said, Here
is a form for universal function approximation,
where it is functions which have a start with an
exponential growth phase, and then have a single
peak, right. So I mean, essentially encoding the
types of properties that we know to be true
with epidemic type models. And so, you know,
that's, you know, there's different ways to think
about it, you know, that, hey, I made this model
as epidemic nice as possible, you know, that's
more high level, but also mathematically, I've
restricted the function space that I'm allowed
to be fitting functions of. And so from the same
amount of data, if my true function is supposed
to be living in this function space, which I've
which I've restricted to, then what I've done is
I just made it so that way, I more easily can be
finding the right function, because I'm finding
as function from a subset of the larger set of
all possible functions right. Now, the last stage
of this universal differential equation process
is to do the prior with the post analysis. So this
is this is always an interesting step. So what we
do here is we say, well, we've trained this neural
network in such a way where it captures all of our
prior knowledge, right? So we've captured all of
our prior knowledge inside of the way that we've
trained this, this this exposure term. So now
let's actually represent it down into you know,
equations right. Now, why do we not start directly
with writing down all the equations? Well,
because that can have curse of dimensionality you
can have, there's exponentially many ways or kind
of editorially be many ways. You can write down,
you know, these, these high dimensional functions,
right. But in this form, we can do the training
process where we've taken into account everything
that we know, all of our prior knowledge, we've
once we once we've found this neural network,
we can start to poke at it and to say, what did it
actually learn? And here we go. could see is that,
you know, I let this neural network be a function
in this case of s of i and d. And one of the
interesting things is it comes out and says, Well,
the best fitting function here is a function of s
and I and you leave D out, which makes sense,
because for COVID-19, exposure to the disease
was not dependent on the number of people who
have died or people who have died, they did have
the disease, but they are no longer infecting
individuals are no longer exposing them, right.
And so this is something they can directly read
out from the sparse identification. Now, again,
the interesting thing here is that, because there
is so much mathematical model around the object,
you can actually interpret it right, because
it's now there is a lot of interpret, you know,
there is model around, it's not a completely a
amorphous object, it is a amorphous black box
within a interpretable piece. So as you start
to learn more information about that black box,
you start to in how it interacts with the rest
model, then you are starting to learn what you
did not know how to model right. And so this
piece of information, like eau de is, you know,
this exposure is not a function of D, this is a
this is a type of, you know, a type of scientific
hypothesis right. Now, the reason why I think
that this is interesting is because it allows
for scientists in the loop, right, we're not just
doing this in like a purely, you know, trust the
machine learning has learned something, you can
actually get some information out to them, people
go back to the lab and say, is made a prediction
about what what needs to be true for this, this
exposure term to be acting the way it is, let's
actually go double check this right. Now, the
other thing that happens here is that you actually
get have some improved your generalizability. So
we kind of see across the board that when you do
this versus a good faith specification process,
you do tend to improve the generalizability
over just having the pure neural network. And
there's a lot of other a lot of reasons for that
kind of comes down to some of the properties of
extrapolation of polynomials. And if anyone wants
to ask, it's something that we haven't been able
to prove, but we have some good ideas that have
the directions routed for what to do there.
So yeah, so someone asked a question here. So
say the neural network is convolutional with
arbitrary channels and feeds how to best combine
t and x in this case, I will go into to some,
some uses of confidence are in convolution
operators for PDS a bit later. So I'll go back
to that. For the COVID prediction example, how do
you determine the functional form of the internal
sparse regression? Yeah, so so we have to make,
we have to choose a, you know, for example, a
library of functions that we want to do the sparse
regression to, it could be things like, you know,
every combination of polynomials, cosines, you
know, trigonometric functions. exponentials. And,
you know, or, like, you know, you so you do have
to make make a choice there about how expansive
you want the dictionary to be, and then you
you simplify it down. But in general, I mean,
that's, that's one of the algorithms involved
here. You know, I could go into more detail,
but it's really want just 111 step of the
process. And, you know, it is it is a modular
choice at that that aspect. Yeah. Now, one of the
things I want to kind of highlight here, you know,
about when I, when I start with scientific machine
learning, I say, Well, you know, it's you're
pouring and model you're pouring in data. And your
goal is to if you have enough prior knowledge, if
you have enough knowledge, right, where knowledge
can come from data, or it can come from models,
as long as you put enough malt knowledge in, you
should be able to get a good prediction, right?
You just need to be able to hit the prerequisite
amount of knowledge right? Now, one of the things
that we've done, why I like to start with this,
this epidemic models, because we had a lot of
work papers and such with, with Sandia National
Labs, where we dug into that idea where we said,
okay, you know, when you know, this is a choice,
right, it's a choice to say there's only one term,
I could have made two terms I could have made,
you know, this entire part of the equation,
neural network, you know, there's a continuum of
how much model you have and how much data you're
relying on, right. And so one of the questions
that we asked is, you know, as you go through
this continuum of more or less model, does it
actually work? As we expect, right? Does it
actually work like that, like this big, big pay
figure, right? Where the more model you dump in,
the less data you need? Or another way to put
that, then is? If you have more prior model,
and that prior model is correct, you know, will
the universal differential equation be able to
give you better predictions from the same amount
of data? Right, that's another way of stating that
same sentence. And we have some work with with
Sandia, which, you know, kind of goes over a
whole load of cases in different epidemic models
with new with simulated data and all these cases,
to really show that that property tends to hold,
right. So you can kind of think that, you know,
this is something across the board where, you
know, with these universal differential equations,
you know, it's not a question of like, how many
data points you need, right? You know, a lot of
these things, we're doing it with 20 data points
or 40 data points, right. So it is a lot less
data than something like a standard deep learning
for Homework. But the real question the the real
answer at the end of the day is, the more prior
model that you have. And the more correct that is,
the less data that you need. And so it is really,
you know, it is really not an you cannot say you
need 30 data points, because whether you need 30
data points is dependent on how much other model
you've put in there, right. So, so, you know, I
would say go go go check out some of this work.
And what I forgot to put in here that they work
with Sandia that really highlights that this
aspect that really just shows the whole continuum
of models, and just shows how adding different
parts of the model into it then incrementally
improves that that that extrapolation performance,
so, but I mean, that's, that's the general idea
here, right, the more prior and mountain model
that you have, the more prior knowledge that you
have, the better we'll end up predicting. Now,
one of the things that we've seen with the
universal differential equation stuff is it's
kind of exploded in terms of have the number of
people really using it in practice. So I'd like
to highlight this work of some folks that, you
know, we actually have this now inside of our
inside of our siamo documentation. And it's one
of our tutorial examples where what they did was
they took these readings of gravitational waves.
This is the LIGO gravitational wave data from the,
from the binary black hole experiment that
first found the gravitational waves, right?
And what they say is gonna go on, well, you know,
gravitational waves, they come from black holes,
black holes are big. And so they, they're not well
defined by Newtonian physics, right? But what if
we assume that we only know Newtonian physics,
right, which is, which is the equations that
they have here, and we augment the Newtonian
physics with, with these neural networks. To
learn what the relativistic corrections would
be, can we learn with relativistic corrections
to meet the motion of two body, large objects
directly from data, right, and what they show is
just that from a small amount of data, right, so
just this small amount from the time series here,
they're able to learn how to augment the Newtonian
mechanics with a correction. And that correction
then adequately extrapolates for being able to
predict the the motion the two body problem,
it changes that from being ellipsoid, which is,
you know, the the Newtonian solution to Alyssa G
pattern. And so if you're interested, I can pull
up the documentation example of doing this, you
know, it's kind of at this point, it's just like
a nice reproducible example that we use to teach
students about how to do this, this this process,
but, you know, it really shows the science of
Machine Learning in Action. But I mean, there's
a lot of examples that do this. So for example,
here's a case with earthquake safe buildings, were
the original model, if you look closely at your
screen, you'll see these dotted lines, where you
know, the original physical model, it could fit,
but it wouldn't necessarily extrapolate well, but
after doing the training, after doing the fitting,
again, you know, the Extrude improves
extrapolation performance. And then the
interesting thing from that, though, is that not
that is improving the extrapolation performance,
but that the but what you can gain from this
process is that it's told you how your original
model is incorrect, which tells you the things
that you did not know before that would be useful
to know about in order to do better engineering.
In this case, they wanted to engineer earthquake
safe buildings. And so this told them what
correction needs to be done to the model
in order to then understand how to build a more
earthquake safe building. Right? Again, you know,
there's two things to this, there's, there's the
extrapolation accuracy aspect, but also the fact
that it's improving what you know, about the
model that you're trying to build. And I think
that that that second aspect is probably even
more important, everyone likes to think about,
you know, lying goes, you know, low low, low cost
with the, with machine learning, but I think that,
you know, improving the way that people build
models, improving the speed at which people
get accurate models, that is probably the more
important aspect here. Now, I can go through
like 50 billion more examples of where people have
used UDS. But I've already done a talk directly on
that. So if you want more more proof points on
it, I'd say go check out this talk. On YouTube,
it goes into a lot of interesting examples
as well, I'm going to cut it here and say,
you know, there's a lot of other examples that
we can that we can show, but now going go so so
knowing that that, you know what the general idea
is, and how and the fact that you know, scientists
and engineers are using this in practice, what
I want to kind of go into more detail here in
a mathematical way is, you know, what, what are
the other things that you can do beyond the basics
of it? Right, so I really was just showing the
showing the basics, what are some things you know,
that you can do to get creative with the UD
formalism? Right? And I think that, you know,
I really want to kind of show is that, you know,
the formalism really allows for generally imposing
prior known structure. So what do I mean by that?
So it's So here's a case that comes from that same
epidemic line of work that we were talking about
where I said, you know, we have this continuum
of models, right? So here's something that lives
in this continuum of models where you might not
know that much prior information. But you you, you
know, but you can impose a lot of detail. So here,
for example, let's say we wanted to model
something like the SAR D case, right? So
susceptible becomes infected, infected,
because either recovers or dies, right?
So so what you can do in this case is, you know,
you can walk into a new situation as a modeler,
you can very easily know, like, oh,
people who are susceptible become
infected, and infected with people who
recover or they die. That's not a very
strong assumption, right. But but it is it
is, I mean, it's a graphical relationship,
right? It's basically saying susceptible people
do not recover without getting infected first,
right? So can you encode that, that that graphical
information into a machine learning structure,
so that way that is prior known information,
right? The UV formalism is very flexible,
right? It's just you put universal function
approximator is in differential equations in
smart ways. So here, for example, is a way to do
this, right? So you can have a neural network Si,
right, you know, so we have three neural networks.
So here's one function approximator. So we say
there's some function, I don't know, where
you subtract it here, and you add it here,
there's another function, I don't know, which is
you subtract it here, and you add it back here,
then there's a third one, right? So there's three
functions, I don't know. But these are the places
where these three functions go. And by design,
what happened, what needs to be true about this,
then is, you know, well, again, there's a lot
of properties that I've just imposed. Here,
for example, the number of individuals who
the certain number of susceptible individuals
is always decreasing, you're going to have a peak
and I right, there's a lot of properties about an
epidemic that I've already imposed directly only
from this information, there's, there's no prior
equations really written down, just structure
written down, right. And so what we're able to
show from this is that you can then, you know,
do this do the training of the neural networks,
in this case, where you train the neural networks,
and then you do the sparse identification of the
dynamics, and you're able to then recover what the
what the exact equations were right, so we can,
you know, simulate data, we generate the data,
we then fit back to it, and then we see that we
can directly predict what these equations are.
But importantly, what we can show is that you
can do this data, you can accurately recover
the equations using this form, with less data
points and with less and with less data points
than what would be required and directly doing
something like you know, the direct Cindy like the
the Steven Brunton sparse identification approach,
right. So because, you know, why, why is that
the case? Well, because we've imposed prior
information here. And so we've really brought down
the the structure that we've need to learn. And so
from the same amount of data, or from less data,
we're then able to recover the same equations,
right. And so this starts to show you that you
can start to get very crafty with the types of
ways that the that you're putting together
function, approximate errs, and using,
you know, any, any drop of prior information
that you have. So another example that came up,
which recently was actually published into Journal
of Chemical Engineering, if I remember correctly,
is a case where we have the this chemical reactor,
and we're running a chemical component over it. So
there is one chemical that is flowing with a with
an advection diffusion process. And then there's
another chemical which is nonspatial. So it's just
a, just an odd process, and they're interacting,
right? We don't know what this interaction is.
So what we do is we model that interaction within
within with a neural network. But we know a lot
about the rest of the process. It's a reaction
diffusion, partial differential equation coupling,
an OD E with with a PDE term, right. And now,
one of the interesting things about this formalism
is but by design now, right, I only have to learn
an R two to r two function in order to actually
learn everything I did not know about this model,
right? So I have spatial temporal data, like, you
know, if you think about it, in the sense, I have
spatial temporal data, and from spatial temporal
data, you know, you know, you have n by n times
t time points, but at every single time point,
the same exact chemical reaction equation should
be occurring. And so what I want to learn is I
just want to learn with a chemical reaction is,
and so even with a small amount of data,
so even with a small amount of time series,
that is still enough information to be able to
recover what the chemical reaction term is. And
once I've learned what the chemical reaction
term is, I can extrapolate into the future
and get things correct, because the important
property was whether I had learned the rest of
the equation in order to accurately model the
whole the whole process, right? So you know,
thinking about it like this. If you think about
as well as a time series problem, right? If you
just say, learn from this time series, How to
predict in the future, machine learning is never
going to learn what you know how to how to make
that the, the red dots go through the red line,
right, you know, or the red line go through the
red dots, it's just doesn't the blue, you know,
the training data that we give it is insufficient
for being able to do that, right. And it's, it's
just not going to, you know, you could look at the
picture, and you can say, okay, you know, machine
learning cannot learn things that it's never seen
before, right. But there is something that hasn't
been seen before, is this prior information of
well, we have all this, this reaction diffusion
equations, and everything written down. And so by,
by virtue of writing down the partial differential
equation form, we've actually transformed a
problem of learning a spatial temporal process,
right? Something that is, you know, learnings,
learning how to output things that are, you know,
N by N, to learning just an R two to r two
function that is a part of a spatial temporal
process. And we can then, you know, under the
assumption under many assumptions about, you know,
the fact that this reaction is independent, you
know, the reaction constants are independent of
the time and location where it takes place, right,
that is, quote, encoded by writing it down as a
semi linear partial differential equation. So by
writing it into this form, we've encoded a lot
of prior knowledge. And it has made it a fairly
easy learning problem that then makes it so that
way from small amounts of data we can extrapolate.
And so, you know, you might ask the question over,
you know, well, what happens in this case of
when we do the sparse identification, this one
was actually a fairly interesting one for doing
this identification. Because, you know, after
we do this process, we we fit the neural networks,
the student went in and did the the identification
process, and saw that there are some very large
cases where the equations were not exactly the
same. As you know, in a will when you do this, in
the case of generated data, you generate the data
with with a known equation for these reaction
terms. And then you go and you say, I'm going
to run this process, I'm going to find out what
equations I get. And you see that the equations
are different, and student was not happy that it
turned out like that. But then we dug into it,
right, we dug into a bit, what we noticed was that
if you actually do a second order Taylor series
expansion of the of the different terms, what you
what you see is that these equations are lining
up, right? They equate, so it's what this really
means, then, is that the sparse identification
is not necessarily able to tell you exactly the
equations that generated your data, right? Because
it's kind of ill posed, right? It's not that
you need infinite data to be able to really,
fully identify the function. But what it can show
you is, it can show you a simple function, which
is locally able to match the right properties of
the true function. Right? So here, when we do the
second order Taylor series expansion, you know
that the two functions are pretty much lined up
directly with each other, right? And so there's
a lot of properties you can get them, right. So
from the Learn kinetics, you know, for someone
who's who's looking at reaction equations, right,
you know, you can say, well, if I have a Q, if I
have a Q squared term, this is a self interaction
kind of reaction kind of term. Whereas a QQ star
term, well, this is this is a interaction between
them. In some of these cases, the chemicals were
non interacting, right. And so so there's, you
know, there's a lot of different input information
that you can pull between these these pieces, just
by learning the equations, even if they're not
exactly the same form that you started with, it is
a form that is representable, interpretable, and
usable for doing the scientific process. Right.
And so, I do like to highlight that this was a,
this is a kind of nice case where we were using
scientific machine learning in an industrial
setting. So we were working with a Formula One
team, this was the Williams Formula One team,
were originally they used a Gaussian process
model that you know, so this is the original
Gaussian process model for being able to model
their speed over ground sensors. So the speed over
ground sensors as they drove around a test track,
they would get this this data that would basically
tell you the orientation of the car, but that
needs to be calibrated using the GPS data from the
from the from the test track, right. And so we can
see here is the calibrated prediction of the car's
orientation from that speed over ground sensor.
And the original model did not take into account a
lot of the physics of the car, right? It basically
just say, Here's my sensor data and here then is
the prediction of what their orientation would be.
And you can see has a lot of these effects which
is the similar to the hallucinations that chatty
PT does, which is effectively you know, it's
giving you things that are non physical right, the
car cannot is not actually moving like this, right
like cars true orientation is a color underneath.
And you can see that a lot of you know, a standard
machine learning model does not necessarily need
to satisfy physics, right? It does not necessarily
You need to satisfy the fact that your car cannot
just bounce around infinitely fast, right? But
what we were able to do is we were able to put a
very simple model of the car's vehicle dynamics,
and say, Well, you know, what we don't actually
know in this in this process is the relationship
between the sensor to the vehicle dynamics. And
so by putting it into that form, a form in terms
of differential equations, which naturally would
be integrated, that naturally then smooth the
process and incorporated prior knowledge about,
you know, the relationship between angular
momentum and velocity and these, these features,
and that made it fairly easy to be able to get a
much more accurate prediction from the same amount
of data. So so I you know, one other thing that
kind of been highlight here is that, you know,
so what is this ut formalism? Well, this ut
formalism, another nice piece about is that
you can rephrase a lot of other Simon methods
as UD ease, which makes it a very nice form a
as someone who writes computational software, to
kind of formalize a round. So here, for example,
is a nice example this, so there is work done by
Han Jensen, and one in a which is methods for very
high dimensional, semi linear parabolic partial
differential equations. And they had this method
where they talked about how you can, you know,
solve these PDE is by using neural networks,
embedded within backwards stochastic differential
equations. I'll skip over the exact details of
of this whole process. But essentially, it's
this is one of the scientific machine learning
methods for solving a PDE using neural networks
in a specific way. And they came up with this,
this formalism where they'd say, you know,
you build this, this recurrent neural network,
you train it with respect to a given with respect
to a given cost function, and then you'll have
something that will be predicting your, your,
your PDE solution, right. Now, the reason why
I wanted to skip over it is because if we start
to talk about things and work with things in this
Ed formalism, it there is actually a fairly nice
way of writing down what their algorithm is their,
their algorithm is a universal differential
equation, which is written as this Ste where
there is this function that it goes right here
that is unknown. And when you learn this neural
network and a neural network that predicts the
initial condition, you satisfy a loss function
on the initial condition. So you solve this
stochastic differential equation in reverse,
and you learn how to predict the that initial
point, then you have the neural networks that give
you the solution to the PDE. Right. So you can you
can go and you can show them and not learn a lot
of different cases that a lot of ways that people
have been looking at, you know, using neural
networks and mixing it with scientific practice,
the general formalism of it is, is as a universal
differential equation, right? So this version of
saying, Oh, I have this recurrent neural network,
this recurrent neural network that was written
down is simply the Euler Marijana discretization
of this stochastic differential equation,
right? And so if you want to then, you know,
generalize their work. Well, one of the ways you
can generalize the work is just discretize, this
Ste using, you know, adaptive methods or higher
order methods, or, you know, all these different
types of approaches, right, so, understanding what
the continuous object that is giving us, you know,
the, when you do this in the UD formalism, you
can write down the continuous object for which
the discretizations give you these Rez nets and
RNNs and things that are then used in a lot of
scientific cases. But you can then start to see
that those are special cases of a more general
object that you can then you know, do a lot with
a lot of nice mathematics more and more simply
on. And so we've been building up packages
for doing a lot of these different types of
scientific and machine learning techniques,
which really did then just uses everything,
you know, everything in the UD formalism. And so,
you know, the core of the software is do UTS well,
and then all these other cases are just well,
this is the, you know, this is this od E with
this discretization, etc. And so it makes it
very easy for us to be able to repurpose the same
underlying training architecture to many different
problems. I think that that's just one thing to
highlight as to you know, we think about this Ed
formalism, one as a way to impose prior knowledge,
but secondly, as a computational tool,
similar to like an OD e solver or a,
you know, Newton's method, right? It's, it's a
way it's a way to be able to turn the scientific
machine learning into a computational tool that
is then repeatable to a lot of other applications.
Now, I want to get back to the
story of differentiable simulation,
right? That's where I started with and, and so
I haven't talked about different differentiating
simulations at all yet. And so why does this
require differentiating simulator? And? Well,
the thing is, I haven't told you anything about
how I train these neural networks yet, right. So
how do we actually train a neural network in
one of these cases? Let me let me show you an
example of This is an example. So here is a case
we're looking at surrogates of climate models,
right? So this is a three dimensional Boston
s approximated NaVi stokes equation. And what
we want to do is we want to learn from the three
dimensional PDE, how to approximate its dynamics
in the z direction, right, just this just the
height column, we just want to turn you know,
blocks of ocean into just one dimensional PDS.
Now, you cannot do that exactly, because well,
you know, now obvious Stokes has curl involved,
you cannot represent curl in one dimension.
But what you can do is you can, you know,
approximate it by, you can take the average,
if you take the original Boston SC equations, you
take an integral average along the slices here,
you can get an approximating PDE. But
that approximately PDE is missing a term,
which then requires you have another PDE, which
has another PDE, etc. So, this is one of these
closer relationships that I'm sure a lot of people
are well aware of. And, but instead of saying,
you know, oh, here's a term that I need to compute
from another PDE, which is missing a term that's
computed from another PDE, what I do is I just
scrap all the extra terms, and I just say, here's
a term that would be computed somewhere else.
But let me learn what that what that term is,
right? So if I did not have the neural network,
this is called the standard conductive adjustment
parameterization to the ocean model. But now what
I'm doing is I'm saying, well, the convective
adjustment equation is missing extra terms,
let me capture that with with a neural network,
let me capture the closure terms with a neural
network, right? So this is just the setup for
for my test case here. And now how do you actually
train this neural network? Right? Well, you can go
back to your data and you can say, well, here
I have data that you know, I get the you know,
average temperatures, I can take the slice, you
know, the the the green slice, the red slice,
I can take slices on the z axis, to be able to
know what this average temperature capital T is, I
can do DD D, T, d t, by taking finite differences
between my data points, right? I can dz,
dy dz, I can calculate this operator by finding
differences. So, you can you can go to your data,
and you can do all this differencing. And if
you do all that difference, and you calculate,
you know, what is delta t delta t, and
what is the right hand side actually,
and then the neural network needs to be the
residual between what the data is giving you,
and what the rest of this calculation would have
would have given you without the neural network,
right. So, so, you know, what I'm what I'm saying
here is that, you know, you can directly go to
your data, apply all the derivative operators,
and then learn and build a data set that is then
you know, the neural network should take in this
value in it should spit up this value as as the
residual right, you build up that data set you put
into pytorch, or TensorFlow, you just train your
neural network. And then after you've trained the
neural network, you stick it into your simulation
to correct your simulation. And then you run it,
right. And so what we did, we did this process,
and we see that this, this did not give us good
results as any of the other things that we've done
with scientific machine learning so far, right? In
fact, it has a very specific behavior to it. So as
you run the simulation, more and more, you tend to
get a drift that is accruing more and more air as
the time goes on. So why would this be the case?
Well, one way to understand what's going on here
is that what we've done is we've came up with a
process for this neural network must be, you know,
my derivative is incorrect. So this neural
network must correct my derivative or control
my derivative. Now, if you're a controls engineer,
if you hear that term, that, you know, we're only
applying control to a neural network control
to our derivative, and then we are getting a
drift term, it should be immediately apparent that
one of the things that we're missing is something
like an integral term that pulls us that makes
sure that we don't have this drift right. Now
another way of thinking about this is the process
of managing your data set to be able to get a data
set to train the neural network has nothing to do
with the simulation process. Yet, the simulation
process itself is imposing errors on the process.
And so if you build your loss function and train
your neural neural network, and then stick into
your simulator, you're not accounting for all of
the properties that your simulation process will
also impose. And so therefore, you're you know,
you're training your neural network without all of
the information that it needed to be the correct
the correct correction, right. Either way you
think about it, you end up in the same point,
where the right thing to do is instead of training
on the derivative data directly, what you want to
do is you want to, what you want to do is you want
to directly use the temperature data, right, this
average temperature data, write a loss function
down, where you solve your model with the neural
network embedded with it, and you check whether
it's hitting the right temperature values, if not
you gradient descent and you change your neural
network until it is right. So instead of training
on the derivative terms, you're training on the
integral of the neural network in inside of your
inside of your model, and what happens when you
do this difference is you get about two to three
orders of magnitude better performance and better
fits. Right. And so you know why, you know, the
other way to understand this, of course, is that,
you know, your your simulation process is imposing
its own errors is discretization errors and all
this properties. And this training process is
actually using the simulator as part of the
loss function definition, and making sure
that it's correcting for that. So that way, when
you actually do the fit, you know, you're you're
getting something that is correcting for for any
of these other errors that you've imposed in that
simulation process, right. Now. Either way, we've
we've now ended up in this formalism, where we
say, well, you know, fitting neural networks on
data outside of simulators, and then sticking them
into your simulators, right does not give us good
results as fitting neural networks as part of the
simulation process. But how do you fit things
as part of the simulation process? Well, then
that means you have to have your loss function, be
something that solves it solves the PDE defined by
the neural network as part of it. And we have
to do the news, you have to take the whenever
you want to take the gradient descent step, you
have to take the derivative of the solution of the
PDE with respect to the neural network parameters,
and this is that differentiable simulation aspect.
And so how do you actually do that process? Well,
you know, we say, the agitate method, but the
agitate method is actually a, there is a lot more
than just one agitate method. And it's you know,
so let me let me describe this in one way. So the
best way to describe that there's more than one
Agile method is to show you that you cannot just
use one choice, you know, one popular choice for
all problems, right. So here for example, the
neural ordinary differential equations paper
describes one Agilent method, which is if you
have an OD e u prime equals f of u t, sorry that z
should be you, you solve this od e going forwards.
And it says if you solve this od E, then you can
solve this od in reverse and and magically,
it will give this this last term, or this term
right here, it gives you the derivative of your
neural network with respect to parameters, right.
And it all it does is it relies on this numerical,
or this mathematical property that if you solve an
OD e going forwards, you know, u prime equals
f going forwards, then solving u prime equals
minus F in reverse should get puts you right back
on in the same place, right. So that's a property
that is true mathematically. But if you actually
look at real equations, that doesn't necessarily
numerically work out. So for example, here,
here, if we look at the advection equation,
if you discretize, the advection equation,
remember, you have to choose a way to discretize,
either using the forward point or the reverse
point, you know, up winning or downloading. And
so if you're, if your wave, you know, if this PDE
is describing a wave that's moving to the right,
you're either choosing you know that your next
value to the right is using your information
from the right or information from the left, it
should be obvious that if you don't ever use the
point from the left to update the point to the
right, it cannot act, it does not actually have
the actual resolution for it for this motion. And
so one of these is unconditionally unstable. Now,
the issue with using an adjunct method as
described like this is it says, Well, if you
solve the OD going forwards, now we're going to
use as part of our agile and approach that if you
solve the OD going backwards with u prime equals
minus F, you will, you know, you use that as part
of this this agile derivation. The issue with that
when you apply it to something like this partial
differential equation is that that is not true
for this PDE right. So, if you solve this PDE,
right, so we discretize this PDE into a set of
ODS, say the up winning equation, you solve it
going forwards, right? If you reverse the process,
you know u prime equals minus F when you when you
reverse this process, the reverse solve will
be down lending and therefore, you know, you
will have chosen the wrong in the wrong direction
and get in unconditional instability. Right. And
so what this really highlights then is that, you
know, there isn't really just one Agile method,
right? So this paper talks about, you know,
here's a way to differentiate odd solutions,
which has over one memory, it turns out
that it has over one memory, but the downs,
it has the downside that is it's not stiffly
accurate. So it's not accurate on stiff equations,
and it is you know, and it's not able to handle
cases like the advection equation right. So,
instead what you need to think about with this
with with differentiating, you know, the these
these different differential equation solvers and
other equation solvers is that the Agilent methods
in the way of calculating derivatives, they
are approximating equations themselves and so,
they have numerical properties and so, similar
to how with an OD e solver, you have to choose,
you know, do I have a non stiff or a stiff ote and
yet these these methods have different properties,
they have different scaling properties and
different stability. Similarly, you have in when
you start looking at the direct approaches, you
count the ways to calculate derivatives of these
differential equations, you also have changes
in the in the properties where, you know, there
are some methods which are stable, but require
more memory, there's some methods are stable and
require more compute. And there are methods that
are unstable, but use less memory in less compute.
And so you have this engineering trade off between
the different ways and the different methods for
for differentiating systems. And you don't just
have a trade off in terms of stability, you also
can show that some of these methods have scaling,
which is cubic with respect to parameters,
which can be fixed by doing all sorts of different
tricks. So this is the paper stiff neural ordinary
differential equations, that goes into a lot of
detail on the differentiation process. But the
key that I want to highlight there is that, you
know, when you just say use the agitate method,
you know, that's that's like saying, eat an
apple, right? It's like, okay, a gala, or a,
you know, Granny Smith or pink, pink lady Apple,
right? It's, you know, there are many there,
it's, it's, it's like saying, solve an OD
E with an OD solver. There's a whole world
of different methods there. And actually, each
of these ways of doing the derivative process,
it really imparts different numerical properties
in different in different stability properties,
and all these different things that come into
play. So when actually doing the UD e formalism,
the difficulty, and the interesting part is all in
the part that I leave out of the talks, which is,
you know, the, how do you do it stably, it's all
in the mathematics of the derivative calculations.
But the key then is that you can, you can do that
UD approach on any kind of simulation process that
you can differentiate. So this is what we've
been building out as the Julius IML ecosystem,
which is, you know, doing things like linear
solve nonlinear solvers, right, if you can,
you know, you can, if your model is to write an
actual integral, well, you can mix that integral
function with neural networks, or you can write
down an optimization with neural networks that PDE
with neural networks write in all of the different
cases where you can write down a mathematical
object where you knew the function, you can extend
this to the case where you have a neural network
as long as you can differentiate adequately
with respect to that process. And so what we've
done with the Giulia ecosystem is we made it so
that with a whole ecosystem of equation solvers,
all connect with machine learning tools, so
that way, you can do this this universal,
universal approximator, mixed in modeling
approach to be able to generalize any type
of scientific modeling to a scientific modeling
that is augmented with neural networks. You know,
and I want to, I want to skip ahead here to
just 111 beat on so for example, we've been
using this a lot with Maderna. But I'll skip over
with that. And the story would with with chaos,
I want to kind of get it to this, this
last story of, you know, very quickly,
can we generalize beyond OTs and PTs. Right, so
everyone talks about OTs and PTs. What can we do
beyond that? Well, it turns out that that the way
to start understanding things beyond just od ES
is to look at chaotic systems, chaotic systems
actually, don't differentiate correctly with
automatic differentiation. Be happy to elaborate
on that in detail. But it turns out that what you
can do though is you get to find new forms of
derivatives and new forms of adjuvants, which
are wild the derivative with of the solution is
not really well defined of a chaotic system, the
derivative of air gotic properties with respect to
parameters is well defined. And you can start to
do things like fit neural different fit od ease on
value, time point values that are more than ileap
Enough coefficient away using, you know, average
properties of the system. And so you know, and so
this then kind of gives you a generalization of
the UD formalism to this case where, you know,
you have a lot of randomness, pseudo randomness
due to due to the chaotic nature of some of these
processes and the error imparted by them. Now, one
of the other interesting cases then is can you do
this in cases like discrete shot models, right,
where derivatives are not normally defined. So
what we what we've done is in this, something
that was recently shown at neurips, was that
in traditional differentiation, you take, what you
do is you take your equation, and you try to find
a derivative. But in the generalized sense,
where you can do is if you have any kind of
random variable, you can try to find a new random
variable whose expected value is the derivative of
the expected value of your original right. So what
you could do is you could say I have I have some
series that does some stochastic process. And what
I want to do is I want to find a new stochastic
process whose expectation acts like the derivative
of my original process. And if you can do that,
which you know, I am running out of time here,
so I'm not going to go over the whole thing. But
the idea behind it is instead of looking at small
perturbations, like small perturbations, what you
do is you look at, you know, small probabilities
of having an O of one change. And when you do that
kind of approach, you can start to build out these
systems where if you were to have say, an agent
based model, you can do directly run automatic
differentiation on that and get the derivative
of the expectation of your agent based model, you.
So if you have an agent based model, you can run
a process that generates a new agent based model
for you, where when you solve this new agent based
model, the expectation of that agent based model
is the derivative of the expectation with respect
to parameters of your original model, right. So
it's like some new model, it's a pseudo model.
But when you run this pseudo model, it gives you
the derivative with respect to expectations of
your original model. And so therefore, you can
use it to be able to say, train neural networks.
So that way your original agent based model is
learning the functions that would define the rate
parameters of your model. And we're able to show
this then in cases like extending, for example,
Conway's Game, a stochastic version of Conway's
Game, or game of life to something, we're then
able to fit the parameters inside of there and be
able to start mixing that with neural networks,
right. So instead of just looking at this world of
you know, we have od ease and PDS, you can start
to say, well, we have all sorts of different
scientific models, we have agent based models,
we have jump processes, Glasby processes, and all
these things. And in any case, where we don't know
functions, we can replace functions that we don't
know with neural networks, as long as we can find
adequate ways to be able to differentiate with
respect to the weights of those neural networks,
we can then learn what these functions are inside
of this process, and then use that to be able to
identify the pieces of the model that we didn't
know. And it gives us a direct generalization of
scientific machine learning to that domain. And
I think I'm about a time there, so I'll skip it.
Skip right there to two questions. I see that I
do have a one one question here. So in the Navi
Stokes 1d model, what what what's the input
for the neural network term doesn't only take
one crit point local. Yeah, so for for that. For
this case, we actually looked at a bit at doing
this in a way that is local and non local. It
turns out that there is some mathematics behind
this process where it says that the operator
in general here should actually be non local
in order to be correct. So we made this so that
with a neural network actually takes in the full
vector of the average temperatures. And we had
another case where it was only local. So making
it local is actually equivalent to making this
be acting as a convolution network. And that
did not actually prefer to perform as well, which
matches up with a lot of the theory then about it
being about the the closure chair and being
a non local operator. Yeah, good question.
Yeah, thanks, Chris, for talking
Transcribed by https://otter.ai